it is the new normal that Indian Airport
staffed sanitized passengers bags before
they enter the terminal the disinfectant
spray is just one of a number of new
measures as domestic flights resumed
passengers temperatures are checked
before and after flying masks a
compulsory throughout the journey and
some were taking extra precautions
the government says only passengers with
symptoms will be tested or quarantined
upon arrival but many states have set
their own rules the Civil Aviation
Minister tweeted Indians saw in the
skies again but not everything went to
plan 82 flights in and out of Delhi were
canceled with little notice leaving
passengers frustrated according to
airport officials that's because several
states said they wouldn't be able to
accept flights which then earlier agreed
to would the number of coronavirus cases
rising the worst had states of
Maharashtra and Tamil Nadu have agreed
to only allow
25 arrivals a day after initially
refusing to accept flights the state of
West Bengal said flights can't land for
another three days as it deals with the
aftermath of cyclone anpan we just heard
that my site has been
I didn't get any notification I didn't
get any meals
I just heard it in the airport so I'm
trying to I'm hitting her back home
airlines are planning to resume about a
third of their domestic flights as the
government tries to restart the world's
fifth largest economy but the industry
faces challenges the Supreme Court has
ordered social distancing must be
observed in airports and on flights
forcing airlines to keep middle seats
vacant and it said the government should
be more worried about the health of
citizens rather than the health of
Airlines Elizabeth Branham al-jazeera
New Delhi